PFT ot the extra show beyond PFT live
where we talk about some things that we
didn't get to and maybe talked about
some things we did get to but we want to
talk about it some more let's start by
talking about what Chris log is talking
about when it comes to Aaron Donald
former teammate with the then st. Louis
Rams remember Chris long left the Rams
before they moved to LA spent some time
with the Eagles in the patriot before
retiring but Chris long said recently
that he knew that Aaron Donald would be
a Hall of Famer from his first practice
that's how good the guy was and Chris
how did the guy not get picked higher if
it was that obvious that the guy was
that good because the the height weight
speed measure balls were not the proper
formula for the position errors unseen
almost like you know a quarterback
that's short where we just go oh I don't
know
so Aaron Donald was kind of one of the
first test cases as far as that
undersized defensive tackle can a guy
that's you know 280 pounds really be a
three technique defensive tackle and
handled double teams against NFL
offensive linemen you know I just think
the everybody saw the talent but I think
everybody was scared of the fact that it
had not been done that way at that
position that's the biggest thing but
Mike that does happen you know I was I
was fortunate enough to be around some
big draft picks right like that you know
like Cadillac Williams was a top five
pick running back from Harvard as soon
as we got him I was like man the first
practice I was like what was this guy's
legit he's gonna be one of the better
running backs in the NFL
Aqib Talib Mike first practice ever he
had to mentor Sepp shion's and he was
covering receivers and I went oh guys
gonna be special like this guy is gonna
be a superstar corner you knew it right
away and that so it's cool to hear Chris
long talked that way about Aaron Donald
wait you were on the same team with the
keep too late by rookie his rookie year
when he got dropped out of Kansas I was
still in the Tampa Bay Buccaneers yeah
yep he was he was a wild child as Raheem
Morris called him he was a wild child
and they knew that and you know anybody
that's been around and keep Talib he's
an awesome guy bright smile always good
mood like one of my favorite teammate
I was ever with and yes he was he was a
little wild exactly right like not in a
mean way but he was wild and the Bucks
knew that but man he could play Mike
like yeah just you know just one of
those guys as soon as he stepped on the
field I said oh he's a little different
than the rest of these guys out here and
I'm not shocked to see that he's having
the career he's had I know this is
supposed to be about Aaron Donovan I
need to add one thing keep to leave his
rookie year that was when they used to
do the rookie symposium where they would
send all the rookies to Canton for a few
days he got into a fight with one of his
Tampa Bay teammates at the rookie
symposium where you know they're trying
to teach these guys how to you know not
get in trouble and they got into a fight
I know an actual fight right a symposium
hike running back were who it was who
the heck he got in the fight with but
you're right I do remember that now that
you're saying that I had forgotten about
that but I'm not shocked by that either
a keebz in a save was on his mind and a
key if you challenge him he certainly is
not gonna back down
well what Chris Long said about Aaron
Donald is I've never seen anybody work
so hard who had so much talent and play
so violently and play with such tenacity
the guy would fight you on the field at
the drop of a hat and I respect that
about him he outworks
everybody I'd be the last person in the
film room usual at the end of camp and I
would go in there and watch tape once
everybody was at home I started going in
there and opening the door and turning
the lights on to find my pen and
notebook and he was in there every night
so works hard puts in the effort has the
god-given ability and one of the best
interior defensive line in the game has
ever seen the Buffalo Bills are at a
weird spot at the running back position
because they've added Frank Gore they've
got TJ Yeldon they drafted a rookie and
LeSean McCoy is still there and recently
LeSean McCoy I had some comments about
his his age he's gonna be 31 he expects
to be motivated by that even though he
had a down year in 2018 TJ Yeldon
says he expects a wait a minute if I
screwed this up no his TJ Yeldon with
the bills right is you're right TJ
Yeldon I get TJ Yeldon
mixed up with the guy the 49ers signed
the guy who's the guy before you have in
common
drafted that's the first time I've seen
your cheeks get red like you were in
battle we're gonna have to retype it now
you don't have to retype it in we can we
can be totally transparent that I had a
little bit of a brain fart that's how
the Ben Roethlisberger brain fart kind
of live but not really live see what we
ordinarily would do I used to do these
one topic at a time Chris right so that
was a point where we'd scrap it and
start over but what the hell let's keep
rolling for Jed's parents hey I saw TJ
Yeldon and I thought Tevin Coleman and I
don't know why I'm telling you Friday I
think we're drafted the same year from
the year they were for whatever reason
I've had this mental block TJ Yeldon
Tevin Coleman and I cannot always get
him mixed up so anyway it's TJ Yeldon
who is also on that Bill's death chart
and he said he expected heated
competition and LeSean McCoy expects to
have a job yeah I expect he's gonna get
squeezed he's due to make more than 6
million dollars this year and I think
that it could get very interesting
especially if TJ Yeldon not Tevin
Coleman is right about the heated
competition because Frank Gore is still
legit yeah and and he does not nearly
get the respect he deserves
and McCoy's been talking about the the
motivation he's received from watching
gore gore is gonna motivate himself
right into a job and it could be McCoy
who's on the outside looking in Chris
yeah I mean I think if a guy like TJ
Yeldon Gore okay let's not forget they
drafted Devin Singletary who's a lot
like LeSean McCoy and theory as a player
the kind of guy that I'll break your
ankles out and you know open space that
if those three kind of proved themselves
to be a worthy trio or you know running
back by committee yeah LeSean McCoy
would be one of those veteran guys that
I'd go he could get released during
training camp or something like that I
don't think that's like totally out of
the realm of possibilities with
evaluating this now you know I still
think of LeSean McCoy he's got some
talent left it's going downhill
definitely he's actually surprised me
with the the play being as good as it's
been at this age for as much wear and
tear as he hasn't as tires but that is
gonna be a legit competition there I
think that's gonna be a new offense in
Buffalo and I expect a lot of big things
and of course that's a big position
for they're running the New England type
of offense they need guys that can do a
lot of different things within their and
find their role within that that Patriot
scheme that they're running in Buffalo
and I feel like LeSean McCoy is one of
those guys who is just enough of a pain
in the butt that when you do detect
slippage and his skills you buy between
that and the money I think what they're
gonna do is they're gonna squeeze him to
take a lot less at some point in August
I think we're gonna say to him look you
you just you six million-plus is not
justified by the production that you
gave us last year and what we anticipate
this year so you take a pay cut err you
take a hike and when you approach a guy
with that kind of an alternative in in
August what are his choices yeah now
maybe he gets lucky and there's a
running back who gets injured somewhere
else maybe Tevin Coleman gets injured in
San Francisco and that creates an
opening for him but but either way the
bills running back position unsettled
and do not assume LeSean McCoy is gonna
be with that team as of week one and yes
it's TJ Yeldon with the bills Tevin
Coleman with the 49ers I'm gonna keep
reminding myself of that over the next
few weeks so I have a down pat when we
come back from hiatus or my hiatus may
be permanent all right Davante Adams top
receiver for the Green Bay Packers
currently and he was raving about a guy
that Chris Sims identified before anyone
else as a potential great player Darnell
Savage the safety who ended up being a
first-round if we were like why is he a
first rounder well just as Chris you
were all over it and now Davante Adams
after an offseason program a believer in
Darnell Sapp yeah and you know the thing
that that's interesting here too is a
lot of the comments you heard about
we're like mental wise all the guys
smart he knows how to play a can do all
these different positions that's what
was encouraging to me Mike because the
physical aspect of him is mind blowing
you know me Rockets up your butt well
this guy's got two Rockets up his butt
that's how fast he is
he is a game changer on that side of the
ball and can do you know in the Box
safety play he could go out and cover a
slot receiver man-to-man and be on them
like glue and then of course he could
play the free safety position and just
be a center field back there and react
to balls and break on it and do that way
but he is a jack-of-all-trades and a
special special talent he was a guy I
didn't really start to watch and get to
towards the end of the draft process
period and when I watched him I wrote
down
my gosh this is a first around safety
this is special that's why we're
expecting some big things in Green Bay
with that defense this year I mean they
they legit got some good personnel there
this year to where I think they could be
a top 10 defense or should be a top 10
defense the yeah I agree with you and
and look we focus so much on that
offense having Mike Pettine still there
having it an opportunity to gel a little
bit more it's an aggressive attack and
yeah we get so caught up sometimes with
one side of the ball for a given team we
just completely lose sight that the
other side may be good enough to be the
right kind of complement to help zactly
my original side of the ball do even
better we free we get ya out if it's a
fantasy football thing or what right but
it's the two sides come together and
influence greatly
exact your defense is the better your
offense is going to be the better your
offense is the better your defense is
gonna be for variety of position points
game conditions right field position
grass turnovers everything right exactly
yes yeah you're exactly right we do we
usually pin it to one side of the ball
or the sexiest aspect of the team and
really the good teams do play
complimentary football to where their
basic premises of what they do on
defense matches what they'd want to do
on offense so they can play that
complete team game and yeah I think
that's what's gonna be interesting about
Green Bay because I think it's for the
first time in a long time with Aaron
Rodgers that we're gonna go okay there's
actually a run game that teams have to
worry about and then I think we're also
gonna be ooh this is a they got a
defense to where Aaron Rodgers isn't
gonna feel like he's got to push the
envelope and score 28 points a game he
might be able to play a different game
this year and go no I think we can win
this game 22 17 and I don't need to take
the chances or do that type of stuff so
that's what I'm really interested to see
how it all unfolds up in Green Bay
there's been some tension between the
Detroit Lions and receiver Calvin
Johnson that traces to the Lions
decision to seek repayment of at least a
million dollars from Calvin Johnson when
he retired without fully earning all of
the signing bonus money he had received
on his final contract and Calvin
Johnson's made it clear you want to make
nice with me you got to pay me my money
back
Barry Sanders a guy who had to pay money
back to the Lions when he retired 20
years ago he seems to think they should
be able to work this out but you know
Hammond Johnson seems to be completely
and totally dug in it's simple it's
clear and you know Calvin Johnson could
have just dug in his heels and forced
the Lions to cut him and I think they
would have cut him he had a huge cap
number for 2016 so he walked away and
shame on his agent for not setting up an
agreement where they wouldn't come after
that money but I think that Calvin
Johnson is right to dig in on this one
this isn't like Barry Sanders who were
properly quit on football it was his
right to do it yeah but it's not the
same right Calvin Johnson was beating up
Calvin Johnson was done a team was done
with him at that price they never would
have kept him for 2016 why'd you make
him take them give the money back in the
first place why not give him back the
money come up with some phony job yeah
Pam and then he's happy and you can have
one of your all-time great players in
the good graces of the organization and
vice versa exactly I mean easily one of
the five greatest players in the history
of the organization and yeah it just
it's a bad look for the Lions and I
understand where Calvin Johnson is mad
about this yeah it's that he's got
plenty of money and that's not the issue
but he's going I would have made plenty
of more money and had a you know a
longer career but you know what I put my
knee on the line for this football team
week after week and just basically
obliterated it to where it's just bone
on bone and he couldn't even practice
towards the end of his career he just
played on Sundays and you know that's
where I think as a player he's looking
at it and going damn okay now you're
gonna make me pay you back and you know
I'm gonna be have to manage my knee
issues for the rest of my life you know
that that's where it's not cool and I
hope that the Detroit Lions do do the
right thing and find some way to
compensate him or make him feel better
about the situation yeah look III agree
with you and I it's just it was a bad
decision by the team it was bad advice
bad agent Hank by Calvin Johnson's
representative to not just get all this
worked out ahead of time because they
weren't gonna keep him and if Johnson
wanted to push the team would have cut
him they weren't going to carry that 26
million dollar cap number into 2016 all
right one more subject and this is an
expansion of what we talked about
earlier we we had a segment that focused
on the best current quarterback
rivalries sparked by Tom Brady and
Peyton Manning getting together again
and and instead of focusing on the best
rivalries
directly I want to take it in a path
that it kind of went on its own during
the show yeah
is there another potential Tom Brady
Peyton Manning rivalry out there Chris I
I see a couple possible but I don't see
the planets lining up in the same way
because here's the problem you have to
have two teams in different divisions so
they're likely to play each other in the
playoffs more likely to play each other
playoffs they're not competing
head-to-head and doesn't get subsumed
within the rivalry between the two teams
right because that always takes center
stage if it's a great rivalry between
two teams it's not a great rivalry
between two quarterbacks but I almost
need to have that that AFC East AFC
South vibe where the Colts are clearly
the best team in the south the Patriots
clearly the best team in the East so
they always finish first in the division
so they always play each other in the
regular season and they encounter each
other in the playoffs so I think until
something like that happens you're not
going to develop a rivalry like Brady
and Manning no and you know some of the
candidates out there it's going to be
hard for them to be in position where
they're winning the division every year
and it's not going to have that that
presumption that we're gonna see those
two two guys square off each and every
season yeah I mean I mean this is the
greatest rivalry I've ever seen I really
think just thinking back about it it's
the greatest quarterback rivalry ever
and you you mentioned all the key
aspects too and you know the other
aspect I'll bring up it is you know
we're in a situation where you and I
we've talked about this a lot over the
last two weeks where we've said it's the
golden era of quarterback play I'm just
afraid that you know so much of the good
quarterback play is going to ruin our
chance to get a rivalry right you know
what I mean okay gotcha looks like
Mayfield and mahomes that's going on the
right track where we might have a
rivalry in the future but then deshaun
Watson gets on fire for two years in a
row and then we don't see you know
mahomes in Mayfield play each other
those are the things I worry about it's
really the overall greatness of quantity
of quarterbacks we got in both divisions
especially in the AFC where you do see
like you said the potential for some of
these great ones where I go man there's
so many great cubies though that they
might cancel each other out to where we
never get that really one-on-one
like Manning and Brady because there was
a there was years there were Manning and
Brady were just so far above the rest of
the NFL that that's what made it so
great and so far above the rest of the
AFC that it just they stood alone and
that's where it was special to where I
don't know if we'll get two quarterbacks
that can just stand alone by themselves
like that in the same conference of her
again yeah I agree with you and if
there's so many factors that go into it
and I just I I wish I would have
appreciated it more while it was
happening because we may not see another
one we might look you gotta have guys
about the same age
I think Baker Mayfield and Patrick
mahomes have a chance but I can't see
the Browns and the Chiefs consistently
winning their divisions I think the
Chiefs yes
the Browns it's gonna be difficult right
so they're not gonna play every year and
may you know if both teams aren't
winning their divisions then it's less
likely they're gonna meet in the
playoffs Oh in the NFC you know Wentz
and Goff we mentioned during the show
the problem is whence is always injured
when the playoffs roll around right and
I you know and and he was injured last
year when they played in the regular
season Nick Foles won that game for the
Eagles against the Rams I mean that's
got potential but but again are the Rams
gonna run that division for the next
five years I don't think so are they
equal is gonna run the NFC East for the
next five years I don't think so there's
no division right now other than the AFC
East where you can point to one team and
say that team owns the division yes I
think I think you need two divisions
like that with quarterbacks who are
young enough that they're gonna be
around for a while about the same age so
they will be around for although here's
Tom Brady here's after Peyton Manning's
retires still going strong but I think
that's what we need
yeah I don't think we're gonna have it
anytime soon no I don't either I think
we'll see a lot of great quarterback
duals throughout seasons and years we're
gonna go amazing but I don't know if
we'll get that consistent rivalry like
we did with Manning and Brady all right
Chris you cut loose for four weeks and
that's something that they'll have us
back see I once we go away you know they
may decide and we're kind of okay
without those guys I don't know I looked
at ball I mean they might I looked at my
contract they still got to pay me so
that you know they can do that if they
want
that's true I hadn't thought of that
angle but here's the bottom line we've
done it before and we've always been
back we will be back in here's the thing
I'm not going anywhere because I'm gonna
continue to do PFT ot on weekdays any
weekday you're bored Chris and you want
to drive over it's only five minutes if
you just feel like you want to you know
get back on the horse for a day come on
over we'll go make a space for you and
we'll have some fun I have a feeling
you're not gonna take me up on that
see you July 29th - Mike a how about but
you know we established that your wife
Danielle at some point is gonna be
saying to you when you go back to work
again yeah so maybe I should tell her if
she ever gets exasperated with you right
tell you to go to studio six fork you
know just to get out of the house for an
hour and we can do this how come you
want to do it maybe we'll do that you
can dangle it out there in front of me
I'll say yes no we'll see how that goes
maybe we'll do that means shut the hell
up and leave me alone
predicated on what I've done the night
before with those decisions to and that
you know this time of the year we don't
know where that could go it's like I
don't have to get up early the night
before it could be a lot of fun so I
don't know if I want to deal with you
the next morning well enjoy the hiatus
and everybody will be back tomorrow with
PFC live PFT ot and like I said I'm not
going anywhere I'm still gonna be doing
videos PFT ot etc during our hiatus so
you know some of us continued to work
even though don't tell anybody this
really isn't work if we would tell
people that they'd stop paying us it's
kind of fun and I'm gonna miss doing it
yeah but Chris it's been a great I guess
is at the end of our say year right
right yeah it's the end of our year
right four weeks late or 2019 officially
begins let's go enjoy it buddy great
work as always we'll see you soon you
too man thanks for having me as always
it is a fun doing the show with you man
all right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports